a suspension bridge has two towers that
rise 500 feet above the road and are
connected by cables that hang in the
shape of a parabola that can be
represented by
y is equal to 1 over 8 960 times x minus
2100 squared
plus 8 where x and y are measured in
feet and x is the distance from the left
tower in the direction of the right
tower what is the distance between the
two towers let's draw ourselves a
diagram
so if we draw the leftmost tower
so if we draw the leftmost tower this is
the left tower right here i'm going to
do an orange
so we have the left tower right here
that tower is at x is equal to zero
right we'll call that x is equal to zero
or
maybe just call that the zero point
right there and then x is just measuring
the distance from that leftmost tower to
the rightmost tower so the rightmost
tower in the direction of the right
tower so this right here maybe the right
tower is right over here
they're both 500 feet high the right
tower is right over there and we don't
know where it is that's what we have to
figure out we have to figure out the
distance between the two but we just
need to know that x is measuring this
distance is measuring the distance from
the left tower in the direction of the
right tower so it's just traditional
just like our coordinate plane that is
what x is measuring if you say x is
equal to i don't know you know a million
feet you're going to get something way
beyond that second tower if you say x is
one foot you're going to get something
in the direction of the second tower
from the left r so that's x and then y
we can assume is the height of the
towers or it's just the height in
general that we're dealing with so this
is the y-axis so we're just dealing in
the first quadrant of the coordinate
plane so that is y
and they're telling us that this
parabola the shape of the parabola can
be represented or even better they're
saying that the that the cable that
connects these two is in the shape of a
parabola so let me draw that let me draw
that parabola right there they're the
same height so the parabola will look
something like this
it will look something like that
and what we can do to figure out or one
possible technique let me draw a better
parabola there let me draw that's even
worse
oh
that's about as good as i can do
one technique for finding the distance
between the two is if we could figure
out if we could figure out the minimum
point of this parabola if we can figure
out the minimum point of that parabola
which is also going to be the vertex of
that parabola that's going to be halfway
between the two towers so if we can
figure out this x coordinate we can say
hey that's going to be halfway between
the two towers and then just multiply by
2. so let's see if we can figure out
this minimum point because the parabola
is symmetric around it and these are
both at the same height so let's see if
we can figure out that minimum point so
let me rewrite let me rewrite this
equation we have y is equal to 1 over
8960
times x minus 2100
squared
plus 8. so how do we find the minimum
point here
well this whole expression that squared
this whole expression is always going to
be positive or it's actually always
going to be non-negative it could be
equal to zero and so this whole thing
is always going to be greater than or
equal to 0. this whole thing i'm
squaring off in orange is always going
to be greater than or equal to 0. so
what is the lowest value that y can take
on well the lowest value that y's can
take on will happen when this expression
is equal to zero and this expression
equals a zero
this part of it equals zero only when x
minus 2100 squared is equal to zero and
that's only going to be equal to zero
when x minus 2100 is equal to 0.
so
x so let me write it this way
equals 0 and i'm just talking about this
orange part when
x minus 2100 is equal to 0 or if you add
2100 to both sides or x is equal to 2100
and when x is equal to 2100 just out of
curiosity what is y well if x is 2100
this thing is 0 times 0 y is just going
to be equal to that 8 there so this
coordinate right here is the coordinate
x is equal to 2100
y is equal to eight and it's going to be
halfway between our two towers so if
this is at 2100 how far is this tower
away well it's going to be twice 2100 so
it's going to be
4200 and everything we're dealing with
this feat is going to be 4 200 feet away
from that first tower so the distance
between the two towers is
4200 feet